Judaism embraces the intricate religious
and cultural development of the Jewish
people through approximately 30
centuries of history stretching from the
Bible to the Roman Empire to medieval
Spain to the Enlightenment to modern
times in the founding of the State of
Israel
the result is an experience that
reflects a mysterious relationship
between religion and peoplehood from a
religious perspective Judaism is a
theistic system but from a peoplehood
perspective it is also the group memory
of the manifold communities and cultures
formed through the ages it consists not
only of Torah divine revelation and
Mitzvahed divine Commandments but also
diverse cultures and languages among
others Hebrew Aramaic Greek Arabic
Yiddish Ladino and English it includes
politics whether in Poland America or
Israel and it includes the whole range
of Jewish education and family life food
and festival music and dance and custom
and humor Judaism is not just a religion
it is the sum total of all the diverse
elements that make Jews distinctive
Judaism as a religion is often
summarized under three heads God Torah
and Israel each of these elements has
assumed varying positions of prominence
throughout Jewish history and an
understanding of them necessarily
unfolds within an ongoing historical and
cultural framework
it was between 1200 and 500 BCE that the
Israelite people of the ancient Near
East began to articulate a radical new
understanding of divinity the belief in
a universal singular God is arguably one
of the greatest religious innovations
among the world's historic religious
systems through the visions and the
voices of prophets the God the
Israelites conceived was all powerful
yet benevolent just yet merciful
rejecting the anthropomorphic tendency
of the time the Hebrews did not
represent God in any human form or
earthly likeness but as a universal
moral God engaged in a lasting
relationship with humankind
these themes initially developed through
oral literature evolved over time into
the written record of the Hebrew
Scriptures meaning literally instruction
or guidebook the Torah is the central
text of Judaism referring most
specifically to the first five books of
the Bible called the Pentateuch
traditionally thought to be penned by
the early Hebrew prophet Moses more
generally however Torah applies to all
of Jewish sacred literature learning and
law these written traditions and the
social relationships derived from them
would continue to unfold in the context
of shifting experiences of homeland
statehood exile and diaspora the Jewish
bookshelf contains many books beyond the
Torah the Hebrew Bible called by Jews
the Tanakh and called by Christians the
Old Testament includes the Torah to be
sure but contains many books besides
notably the books of the prophets the
Book of Psalms and the book of Job
beyond the Bible the Jewish bookshelf
contains books of law ritual scriptural
interpretation homilies philosophy
history poetry and much else composed
from ancient to modern times among these
works perhaps the best known is the
Talmud a massive work composed in
Babylonia modern-day Iraq in the first
centuries of our era in literary form
the Talmud is a commentary on an earlier
work the Mishnah and in turn became the
focal point of innumerable commentaries
written in the following centuries for
religious Jews the Talmud is the
foundational document of Jewish law to
this day from both traditional and
historical perspectives the bond of
peoplehood has informed Jewish identity
throughout the centuries conversion to
Judaism is possible but the concept of
family heritage remains paramount the
convert is welcomed as a new adopted
member of the family in political terms
Jewish statehood found expression in
early unification of the Israelite
monarchy under King David though
beginning with the exile in Babylonia
this was followed by much longer periods
of dispersion to a varied set of global
cultural social and
contexts living apart in diverse regions
over many centuries Jews have taken on a
multiplicity of cultural and even racial
characteristics but nonetheless distinct
elements of Jewish identity have
persisted throughout a history of
Diaspora theological and ethical thought
within Judaism also continues to respond
to the changing historical context
through which Jewish communities of
journeyed Philo a first century
Alexandria ro of such a guy of 10th
century Babylonia Maimonides of 12th
century Spain and Egypt many great
Jewish thinkers have taken pains to
integrate the Judaism of the Torah and
the Talmud with the best of contemporary
thought modern times have seen the birth
of secular Judaism of Jewishness as
ethnicity peoplehood and culture shorn
of religion the most famous Jews of
modern times Karl Marx Sigmund Freud and
Albert Einstein
not to mention Woody Allen Mel Brooks
and J robert Oppenheimer all were or are
secular Jews Judaism remains vibrant in
today's world as Jews understand and
express their Jewishness in numerous
diverse ways
you